time to meet the king-beyond-the-wall
this season my character Jon Snow got a
bit more freedom and he's kind of
playing is that age-old story of being a
spy and going into the the enemy camp
and then the problems that arise with
that about not knowing where your
loyalties lie whether it's with the
people that you've left behind or the
people you're trying to infiltrate my
brother inside his army the worth a
thousand fighting against it there's a
big internal struggle within the
character in the season and it was it
was quite difficult by that at times how
does it feel knowing those metal died so
you could skip through the snow the
little savage girl but device yo known
better trusting it had a broken ankle
this season and that was the most
challenging thing it's a very physical
role and I've got I've got a lot of kind
of action scenes this season like a lot
of people do and I had to kind of work
around that but it did work out and I
could do the fight sequences which I
love doing
but if you've read the books and you
know what season 3 and tells you know
it's an incredibly high impact season
there's a climbing sequence which I
think people are I think we've done real
justice to I feel that this season there
is going to be more danger and I think
that that is you know the secret to its
success in its continuing appeal as well
should have took me while you had the
chance speaking for Egret I feel
certainly that you see the characters
arc and she has a fabulous journey and
and you see a kind of tough aside of her
as well but there's also her walls get
broken down and there's a kind of tender
side as well which is fantastic and you
know I think that that's gold dust for
any actor because you get to be
versatile come along chance now Suns
have some you know really high moments
really low moments it's roughly going to
kill Sansa's brother
even if he does Santa will do her duty
won't you little dove I mean it's a very
emotional character for sure and you
know having really good to do all that
crying kind of emotionally and
physically James like a your grace
whatever my traitor brother has done I
had no pot you know that I beg you to
local seller of this outrage the show is
kind of an adaption of the books
everything is pretty much the same with
one or two kind of differences and
season three there are kind of bigger
differences i guess and it stirs when
you put us the book readers will be
super short i think this is the new aria
we're seeing this year i can name anyone
he'll kill him she really just developed
this year and i'm excited to see the
audience's reaction to kind of the
decision she makes and the things that
she says to people do you believe them
no my lord anyone can be killed I'm
insight about season three because it's
sort of a crescendo it's like the end
almost of the first act of this brand a
story saga that we're on with all my
heart your grace I have come to love you
from afar the fortune of characters
really rises and falls in an epic way
fight for the side that fights for the
living did it come to the right place
the truth is that the division center in
two novels is almost arbitrary I mean
I'm writing one story that has a
beginning and quite a lot of middle and
and hopefully an end